done in about 20 seconds
there we go and Welcome to our LinkedIn
live streaming audience our YouTube live
streaming audience and our WebEx
audience to
this
Digital Data science Master Class our
LinkedIn live series
sorry in our learn it live series uh
data science master class today is on
how fintech apps like invest money make
credit decisions
using machine learning techniques
instructor shubham Pandi is here and he
will be taking you through the topic
um if you're on the WebEx
school today please put your questions
for show them in the Q a panel you can
also chant to all panelists I'll be
tracking those as he's presenting and if
you are uh watching through the live
stream put your questions for show them
in the
um comments
or chat and we will have somebody
transcribing those from
us to share with him
we'll also be doing a couple of audience
polls if you're on WebEx you should be
seeing
a poll coming up now
this is pretty straightforward if you
are watching live stream you can put in
the
answers into your chat if you like
basically how much work experience do
you have
and
we also like to check in with people on
how they're doing
world's been in turmoil for the last
couple of years with lockdowns and work
from home and surges
hopefully we're on the other side of
that now but
we'd like to check in to see how people
are doing
so we'll give this about
five more seconds
um
poll result
and we have a fairly even distribution
of experience we have about 30 percent
of our audience who are still in school
but we have
um
about a third of our audience who are
greater than five years of experience so
broad spectrum show them and um the
other good thing is that more than 90
percent of our audience says they're
doing well or at least okay today so
that's good to hear
and
um by the way my name is Stuart Creek
I'm a marketing manager here at simply
learn
and I'm going to uh turn over the
presentation
right now so let me stop sharing
slides and turn it over
you
one moment
all right you should have the ability
now
share your screen
uh let me unmute you as well I've got
your your your live now
thanks Stuart uh am I audible loud
enough
yes
and we see the we see the uh
presentation
wonderful
a very good morning uh very good evening
to all of you I'm so excited to meet you
all live today it's my second YouTube
live
so a quick introduction before we
proceed for the discussion
uh I carry uh more than a decade of
experience around 12 years of experience
into AI into machine learning data
science
my role in the corporate has been into
strategy Consulting
and I've been working as a data
scientist
uh right from the beginning of my career
I've been in touch with academics
I have a passion for teaching
so
I used to teach over the weekend
sometimes at one point of my career I
was a full-fledged corporate trainer
where I used to visit the premises of
different companies and I used to
facilitate workshops these are a few
companies where I have facilitated
workshops on different analytical tools
and techniques Citibank almost
throughout India it was long time back
though HP Global logic Services ITC PWC
Monet American Express I worked with
American Express as well for good five
years exit to Singapore uh Infosys
cognizant multiple batches circle group
from Europe Zander Talent Indigo
Airlines couple of batches batches it
was a long assignment and a very
interesting one that interview Analytics
around four batches we are still uh
into that
I'm associated with multiple training
Institutes
uh corporates
and uh different in different
universities as well but I believe
simply learn our association with simple
learn has been the greatest it has been
close to seven years
and uh we are going together
my expertise
right from the beginning of my career
I've been using SAS for last five years
it has been python all the way you know
uh the era of Open Source tools and
python is just amazing
are also I've been using since a long
time sps's table I use extensively Excel
I love
and these techniques I use as a part of
my day-to-day work so this is a brief
about myself you can always follow me
over LinkedIn
so let's get to
the point of concern the business we are
here to talk about
so we are going to discuss today
credit risk
how we measure credit risk
and why credit risk is important all
that discussion we are going to have
so I'm very excited to share my
knowledge with you but I want to have it
fun discussion so I want you to
participate in the discussion I hope you
can share your
thoughts your ideas your questions over
the chat box yes
I hope you are equally excited
right
wonderful
bread
so
that's great
so this is great to see
just got to hear that we have such a
diversified set of audience
we have freshers we have also those
people who have around five years of
experience more than five years of
experience 10 years of experience so
it's a very Diversified audience so it
will be definitely fun and learning for
everybody oh great to know Priyanka
that's great
so credit risk
but before credit risk risk
we all know this is a very important
term if you're going for any initiative
any new project
anything we always talk about risk
we always talk about the chances of
failures
right in general
or
indigenouses as well
so it is important to measure risk
because we are not God we cannot see the
future
but yes
uh
statistics Analytics
machine learning algorithms help to
measure risk and if you are able to
measure risk
we are aware of it we are we are well
aware of the future
and we are then able to take calculated
risk
we are able to make better decisions
right
now let's talk about credit risk
so what do you think about credit risk
before I talk about it
what is credit risk what do you think
about it
let's gather the thoughts here first of
all
so on the screen you can see two boxes
predator
and debtors
and you see uh
the relationships
so when I talk about credit risk I come
across these
keywords
thanks guys for your inputs
NPA
probability of risk
default on payments
thanks guys for your inputs
so Predator which is also called as
lender
lends money to debtors
debtors or Borrowers right
and borrowers or debtors are supposed to
pay
the money back with interest
this is the process you have in front of
you
right
now
nobody has seen the future
Predator would give money to debtor
based on
some important factors
by checking if you collaterals
by looking at
the ability of data to pay back the loan
right
so
the event of a borrower
not being able to make
the required payment to repay their debt
is called the default
okay so creditors have to mitigate this
Predators have to protect themselves
against
these type of events events of default
okay to mitigate that lenders must
assess credit risk associated with each
transaction
each alone
okay
the likelihood
that a borrower would repay their loan
to the lender is called credit risk
the likelihood that a borrower would not
repay their loan to the lender is called
credit risk
okay
yes guys
credit scores are checked credit scores
in India they are called as civil scores
in U.S
uh FICO scores right so those scores are
definitely checked
so
are we clear with the definition are we
clear with the concept here credit risk
would we say the Predator text fix and
debit or takes risk so here creditor
takes risk right
so risk is with the Creditor
at the present
let's talk a little more about the
importance of credit risk assessment
why it is so important
so it is very important to know that
lender would be able to pay back the
loan
it is important to know that lenders
inability or failure
to estimate borrowers probability to
default
yeah
it will reduce MPA
and subprime lending
may lead to very catastrophic
consequences as well
do you know the reason of
Great Recession
get Great Depression in 1930s
all because of this only
Global financial crisis we had in 2008
all because of this only
I will be
so if you don't measure the credit risk
and give loan without measuring it it
creates big problem it creates a ripple
effect for sure KP
so now we have understood what is credit
risk why it is important let's go
further
one more thing I want to talk here
before I talk about the technique
basically quantification of credit risk
so credit risk can be Quantified in
multiple ways there are multiple
methodologies to quantify credit risk
uh some of these I will just note down
here
anybody aware of it anybody from
Financial background aware of
how we can quantify credit risk
absolutely
there are several different score models
several ways to do creditors modeling
probability to default probability
of default
finding out probability of default is
one way are you able to see what I am
scribbling here
is it legible
I'm just setting up the context here
Brit
then there is something called loss
given default
then there's something called exposure
at default
yes absolutely
so we've got really limited time so
today we are going to focus on
probability of default
how we can find out the probability of
default
that helps big time
to understand
the ability of
data to pay back the loan
what are the chances that
data will default
okay so that is a very important
aspect to look at so today we'll be
focusing on the first one
then later on when we'll meet we can
talk about other two as well and a few
more very interesting
risk assessment uh modeling techniques
so uh Basel standards We're not gonna
talk about
today the topic of discussion is how we
can use classification algorithms to
find the probability to default
okay I told you there are many ways to
assess
uh the risk credit risk
but today we are going to focus on only
the classification methodology although
you can use regression
and there are many other algorithms as
well for risk assessment
from different perspectives okay it is
not limited to only classification
but since we have limited time so we'll
be uh generalizing all our energies into
classification
okay
so classification first of all what is
classification it is a technique which
helps to decide the class level category
of any scenario
this technique helps to determine the
extent to which the scenario belongs to
any class
this is achieved by creating a
statistical model from the scenarios
with known classes labels categories
so I have just read it for you
how classification is going to help our
cause here
for credit risk modeling
let's try and understand that
so for any borrower
what do we want to know
whether the borrower will default or not
whether the borrower is possible
defaulted or not
possible
defaulted
or a good customer
good borrower
with me
for any bar what we just want to assess
whether that person
is more inclined towards
default Behavior or the customer is a
good customer
the borrower is a good borrower we just
want to understand these two aspects are
you with me
so it becomes a classification problem
that way
it becomes a classification problem that
way
first class is possible defaulted the
second class is good customer
maybe 0 or 1
yeah binary
so for each borrower we want to
understand whether the borrower is
possible defaulter or the borrower is a
good borrower
he or she is not a defaulter
that you want to understand so basically
this becomes a classification problem
it becomes a classification algorithm
to be used
right
before I explain to you
classification algorithm
classification model
we need to first of all understand what
is the model
very quickly though because there are
many people here who are not aware of
what a model is we talk a lot about
uh model like right now as well we
discussed many times we uttered this
word many times that we are going to
create Prejudice model what is the model
can you share your thoughts very quickly
very good points
okay
very good points coming our way
okay thank you so much for your inputs
let's look at one scenario
suppose uh you are working for a bank
okay and Mr a
you find who has applied
for a loan of amount 250 000 dollars
you're working for a bank
and you find Mr a applying for a total
loan amount of 250 000 this is the loan
amount
when you checked the credentials of
District a you find that Mr a has age
uh 27 years
Mr a is earning
to say
3500 dollars per month
uh credit score for Mr a is uh 680
and Mr a uh resides
in New York New York suburb
okay
you get to know this much detail about
Mr a
now based on this detail you need to
decide whether you should disburse loan
to Mr a or not
so you are kind of confused how to
decide about it
so what you did you approached your
manager
you asked your manager how to go about
it your manager told you back don't have
to worry just figure out the chances of
default from Mr a
let's just find out the probability
that District a would be a possible loan
defaulter
and based on that decide about it
so what you have been asked to do is
find
probability
that
Mr a
would be
a possible
defaulters
this probability you have to find out
so everything reduced to only finding
out probability
so all the task has been boiled down to
finding out probability that a would be
a possible defaulted
now how would you find out this
probability
how would you come up with this result
for that purpose
probably you will look for similar types
of people
similar types of profile profiles you
may have you may want to look at
right
are you with me
do you want to check the similar types
of profiles your experiences just think
about it when uh
suppose anybody's family member is not
well at all
okay and that person goes to the doctor
and asks the doctor what are what are
the chances of survival of my family
family members
doctor would say uh around 90 chances
are there for the survival
just think about it how doctor would
answer this question how a doctor comes
up with this number 90 percent
how doctor would come with this number
90 percent
doctor would basically use
his or her experience
looking at the medical reports
absolutely
looking at his past
experience with different types of
similar patients
he would come up with this number 90
maybe he
diagnosed hundreds such patients in the
past and out of 100 patients 90 percent
90 patients survived
okay so based on that doctor would say
that there are 90 chances
right
so it's not about only looking at the
patient's health
doctor will also use his experience
he would definitely assess
those patients
who are in the similar type of health
condition
and how many of those patients actually
survived so that doctor would look at
the same thing we have to do here as
well so if you need to do this analysis
you would need to look into similar
types of profiles
so how would you get there you may
probably look into the data of your own
customers
you would probably look into the data of
your own customers where you have the
details about
their age
you know income about your customers
you know about their credit scores
you know where they reside so you know
everything about your own customers
what extra information you have for your
customers
what is that extra information
that extra information is about whether
they defaulted in the past or not
so for your own customers you know
there today their credentials you are
aware of their age income credit score
residence but their your own customers
you know about them whether they
defaulted in the past or not
are you with me
suppose you look deeper into your
customers
you try to develop some relationships
you try to come up with some patterns
and after doing all of that you come up
with
a rule you come up with one
fact that
people who have
out of your customers who have age lying
between 25 to 30 years
who have income
lying between three thousand dollars to
say thirty seven hundred dollars
okay
and the credit score uh if falls between
say
uh 700
and 650 to 700 and those who reside in
Suburban areas
these type of people when you checked in
your own customer data
you'll find that there are
thousand such
customers
there are thousands such customers
who have aged between 25 to 30
income between 3000 to 3700 and today
the score between 60 to 700. there are 1
000 such people out of one thousand
nine hundred
and sixty customers
paid back the loan
without any problem
so around 96 people
96 customers were good customers they
were good borrowers now tell me
for this guy what will you decide
you would give this guy loan or not he
would disburse loan to Mr a or not based
on this data
so
the highly likely
it's highly likely that based on this
data any bank would disburse loan to Mr
a
it is highly likely
okay maybe loan amount also you pick
here I miss that loan amount
okay loan amount is also there
okay
now this one thing
this is
a part of the model only you got this
from the model
you got this pattern from the model
so just think about it
this pattern which you have derived from
the data
this tells you that there are 96 percent
chances that
Mr a
would not default
right
so you're deciding based on the
observations you have
right so is it hundred percent conform
is it guaranteed that Mr a will not
default
no
even if instead of 960 people even if
you have all the thousand people
even if you have all the thousand people
all the Thousand customers good
customers
suppose you have all the people
good customers
even then you just can't say that Mr a
will not evolve right why
it is a model why
so let me tell you
model you are creating here this rule
you are coming up with based on your own
observations
based on the sample you have
right
so mortar does not give you the truest
possible relationship but you use it as
a truest possible relationship am I
right
so a model is nothing but a hypothesis
never get confused
I would suggest you to read
no freelance theorem anybody read that
theorem no freelance theorem
read up that theorem
it will be fun for you to know
a lot many things people have a lot many
confusions about modeling so a model is
nothing but
a hypothesis
created from the observations for the
population for the data generation
process so a model is nothing but a
hypothesis created from the observations
created from the sample for the
population for the data generation
process
so this should be very clear to you
absolutely
so this kind of model I want to create
basically I want to find out the
probability that a would be a possible
default for this purpose we have
multiple algorithms
logistic regression is very famous apart
from logistic regression we have
decision trees naive based algorithm K
nearest neighbor algorithm and we have
many Ensemble techniques as well
okay but today uh we'll be discussing
here logistic regression okay
so let's get started with our discussion
on logistic regression
so idea of today's class is to
uh talk about logistic regression for
sure it will also give an gift uh give
an idea to you how we conduct classes
online
the level of interaction with the
students
okay and especially in machine learning
you have to have a very Optimum mix of
mathematics
and programming
you cannot go too deep into mathematics
but at the same time shallow knowledge
on mathematics Maybe
inviting for trouble
so you should know
mathematics to some extent
and programming is also very important
so programming part will not be able to
touch upon today but mathematics part
I will definitely be discussing and
we'll be discussing mathematical aspects
in a very intuitive way
so if you're learning logistic
regression for the first time it will be
very useful for you
so we need to first of all understand
here what do we need we need probability
to default
okay
so we always want to find out
probability as a function of
any attribute
of the loan applicant so x i is one
attribute any one attribute of loan
applicant
this may be
uh credit score this may be age this may
be
loan amount okay
or it may be a combination of all
okay
so that's how it is
so you basically want to find out a
relationship between probability
and linear combination of
attributes of any borrower
that's what you want to develop
if you are able to develop such a
function you can always plug in the
value of attribute and you can get the
value of probability to default so Y is
equal to 1 1 stands for default and 0
stands for non-default
so probability to default is y i is
equal to 1.
okay
now the problem here is
and obviously when probability to
default is uh F of beta naught plus beta
1 x 1
beta naught and beta 1 are
unknowns
okay beta naught and beta 1 are the
unknowns you don't know about these two
right now
you want to establish such equation you
want to establish this relationship
so probability default is this so
probability not to not default will be 1
minus this probability 1 minus F of beta
naught plus beta 1 x I right
here f is the logistic function and beta
naught plus beta 1 x i is the linear
expression in independent variable
here something tricky here
probability value always is false
between 0 to 1 right
probability value always falls between 0
to 1. so this function should also be
such that it returns values between 0 to
1.
right
we are in search of a function which
returns values between 0 to 1 and our
search ends at this amazing function
this function is
sigmoid function
it is also called as logistic function
so we are in search of a function
which returns values between 0 to 1.
sigmoid function helps here
sigmoid function is written in this way
e raised to the power Z
the z may be anything any input e raised
to the power Z over one plus e is raised
to the power Z you know what is e
e you you are aware of yes you should
know there's very basic mathematics
Euler's number it is the value is around
2.7 something it's an irrational number
raise if you are raising any power
here
okay
so in the numerator you see you have 2.7
something raised to the power Z in the
denominator you have 1 plus the same
thing
don't you think denominator will always
be more than the numerator
am I right
so this value will always be less than
one
and it is it is
going to be always positive as well for
obvious reasons right so this will
always return the value between 0 to 1.
so f is basically F should basically be
sigmoid function so you can pass this
input
you can pass this input to sigmoid
function so basically your probability
to default becomes e raised to the power
beta naught plus beta 1 x i over 1 plus
e raised to the power beta naught plus
beta x i
okay
if you do here cos multiplication
and then you will take the log
you will arrive at this equation this is
called as
logic equation
okay
p over 1 minus P it is called as odds I
hope you are aware of this term odds so
Ln Ln means log on base e
so log on a on base e of odds is equal
to Beta naught plus beta 1 x i so
basically log of odds is equal to linear
combination of independent variables
isn't it very similar to regression
are you with me
is this not very similar to regression
just that in regression you have here y
right
now what is the problem at hand
what problem we have at hand right now
we have probability now
as e raised to the power if I stick to
this form e raised to the power beta
naught plus beta 1 x i over 1 plus e
raised to the power beta naught plus
beta 1 x i
okay
now tell me
if I want to find out the probability of
default
using this equation
suppose x i is nothing but
uh
X is nothing but your credit score
for example credit score
if x is nothing but your credit score So
based on credit score if I want to find
out probability to default
what is stopping us here what we don't
know here
what is unknown here in this equation
otherwise we can plug in the value of x
i here
and get the value of probability so here
in this equation what do you see as
unknown absolutely unknowns are beta
naught and beta1
these coefficients are unknown
so basically now we need to train the
model
we need to train the model based on the
data
so training the model what do you do in
training in training the model you
basically find out the parameters so
these are the parameters you need to
find out the moment you have these
parameters you can put the values of
these parameters here and you can get
the relevant probability not a big deal
for you
right so to establish logistic
regression model we need to determine
the appropriate values of beta naught
and beta1
now how do we find out the values of
beta naught and beta1 this is something
we need to understand
we'll probably get into our own customer
base our own customer data I'm right
from that data we will train the model
we'll find out beta naught and beta from
that data
are you with me
let's look at any one record any one
scenario any One customer
okay
so
on the top left corner
I'm writing here Mr a has applied for
the loan
so I'm not looking for Mr a Mr a uh
uh we need to assess whether to give
loan to Mr a or not right so we will not
be able to train our model based on the
credentials of Mr a
we need to train our model based on
the customer data am I right
we need to train our model based on the
customer data so if I look at any
customer
suppose the customer is Mr
X
Mr X has
alternative score 750
Mr X earns for 4500 dollars per month
Mr X
has applied for a had applied for the
loan of 250
000 dollars
okay and he was a good customer so you
have one you have zero against Mr a
means Mr a did not default
okay that you know about Mr a
so you know about Mr a that Mr a did not
default in the past Mr a has this
credential now I need to train the model
based on this scenario
for that purpose just think about it and
tell me
for this guy
probability
that Y is equal to 0
means probability that
this guy will not default this
probability if I find out using this
equation that should be maximum or
minimum
this probability should be maximum or
minimum
if I want to train my model based on
this data
based on this record this probability
should be maximum or minimum
just think about it
if it is minimum suppose it is minimum
means it is suppose 0.2
what will be the predicted class here
if the probability is 0.2 what will be
the predicted class
predicted class will be one
right
so predicted class and actual class will
not match
so you want this probability to be
maximum
am I right
so that the predicted class
an actual class both are
close
do you follow this
so you want
probability of Y is equal to 0 maximum
let's take one more example
Suppose there is Mr P
okay Mr P has uh credentials like uh 35
years of age Mr B applied for uh 150 150
000 dollars
Mr B Ernst
uh twenty nine hundred dollars per month
Mr B Mr P has created a score of say 800
okay
and Mr B
actually defaulted in the past
okay Sachin
Mr B defaulted in the past
now if you need to
train your model tell me probability
that Y is equal to 1.
probability that Y is equal to 1 should
be minimum or maximum
probability that Y is equal to Y should
be minimum or maximum
again maximum
right
so this is something very good so
whether it is probability of zero
or it is probability of one we want it
to be maximum
does this make sense
split
so for probability of observing actual y
probability of observing actual y for
any record probability of Y is equal to
probability of Y is equal to 1 raised to
the power y i into 1 minus probability
of
1 probability of Y is equal to 1 raise
to the power 1 minus y i
do you understand this
do one thing
just put here y i is equal to 0.
just put here 0
what will you get
if you put here Y is equal to 0 you will
be left with 1 minus p
did you follow
this term will become 1
if Y is equal to 0
and if y i is equal to 1 this this power
will become 0 so this term will become 1
so you'll get this value so in general
you can write like this for for any
record probability of observing actual y
for any record you can write like this
and that you want maximum
for all the records
so for all the records you want this
maximum
if I want
a Consolidated result for all the
records
don't you think we can multiply these
all probabilities by considering these
probabilities as independent events
so what we are doing here we are
multiplying these probabilities for all
the records
Do You observe this here for all the
records we are multiplying these
probabilities this we call as likelihood
function
and if you look at this function if you
look at this expression on the right
hand side
what are the variables in this
expression
what are the variables in this
expression only beat it up
only unknowns here are beta values
what do you want this function to be
minimum of minimum or maximum since you
want each probability to be maximum you
want the multiplication to be maximum as
well
so what you do here you maximize
so to find out the values of beta
coefficients to find out the values of
parameters to train your model what you
need to do you need to maximize this guy
so now
everything boils down to
maximizing likelihood function
so this is also called as maximum
likelihood estimation
because you find out the coefficients
you find out the parameters you train
your model by maximizing the likelihood
function
is this making sense to all of you
now maximizing can be done in multiple
ways
this is a technique called gradient
descent
and there are many variants of gradient
descent
they can be used
to get this thing get this thing done in
a very interesting way
you actually derive your loss log loss
function as well based on this we don't
have enough time to talk about loss
function but I'm just giving you ideas
so log loss you can derive from this
expression only
okay
so that is about model building
basically model building
in model building what do you do you
find out the generalized patterns you
find out the relationships
okay after finding out the relationships
after finding out the patterns it is
important that you validate because
ultimately it is the hypothesis which
you create for the population so you try
your best to make it more generalized
but still you need to always test it
for testing
you have multiple metrics
you have accuracy inaccuracy what you do
you look at all the records and out of
those records you check
the records which you have
classified accurately in the test data
so you create one data
you separate out some data for the
testing purpose so on that test data you
do the prediction you do the deployment
of the model
and over there you can check the
accuracy accuracy is not the only
parameter we look at other parameters as
well like we look at
decision we look at recall
we look at f-score etc etc so it's a
long discussion
I think we
don't have much time left now
so maybe later on when we'll meet again
we'll talk more around these all aspects
and ultimately you create the ROC curve
and with the help of Roc curve you
figure out the distinguishing ability of
any model
so today I could not cover a couple of
slides
because we got involved into too much of
discussion and which was good uh we can
cover these all topics maybe later on
when we'll meet next
but it was nice interacting with you all
thank you
okay do you have time
for a couple questions
sure
please go ahead okay
so we have some questions that came in
um
is the choice of regression model
specific to the variables in the data
available
so are you going to choose different
modeling techniques for different types
of data
or is it based on the decision you want
to make
but basically
uh it's a very interesting question
the decision uh to select the right
model depends on data
as well as on the question you are
answering
so it depends on both the factors
so you have to take in cognizance of the
objective the problem statement the
business scenario also you need to look
deeper into the data
what your data is telling you
yeah
um and can a classification model
output more than just the binary
decision between 0 and 1 can it do a
multi-level decision of you know zero
one two three four that type of thing a
very good question
and I really like the inquisitiveness
here
so classification models are not limited
to only binary classifications
you can definitely do multi-class
classification
there are multiple ways you can do that
they're very interesting techniques to
do that
like one versus all technique is there
there are many other techniques
so it is definitely doable
okay
and
when we're talking about uh
the relationship between the statistics
of these models and how the machine
learning system works
um
but how do we Implement into
machine Learning System the ability to
take in data classified according to the
model and build up its
knowledge base so to speak
sure
so let me tell you uh when we create
machine learning models when we create
machine learning tools
our approach
becomes a little different and we focus
towards scalability
we focus on agility of the model
we focus on optimization we focus on
automation so these aspects are very
important when we go for building
machine learning tools
um
and then I guess because of the time I'm
going to ask this one last question you
had mentioned a recommendation for
something people should read up on could
you repeat that please
okay uh I was talking about the modeling
part and I mentioned no freelance
theorem it's a very simple theorem which
talks about models so no free lunch
theorem
the no free lunch theorem okay yeah
and
by the way
the expression there's no such thing as
a free lunch it's an old uh expression
but it was made popular in the 1950s by
the science fiction writer Robert
fine line just thought I'd mention that
because it's one of the famous things
that you said in one of his books there
ain't no such thing as a free lunch yeah
okay
um
so we've gotten to the end of our hour
and
um
I'm sure that you will share with me the
slides so that I can share them with the
audience in our follow-up email
I just want to conclude with a couple
more
things real quick
first off I want to thank shubham for
being here
um I want to mention that typical Garden
offers a number of data sets and
certification programs uh with
instructors like Sherman
um some of them are
single courses which are
a few weeks but most of our programs are
multi-course programs that go from six
months to 12 months
they have integrated
Labs that you do on the platform through
your browser you have online live
virtual classrooms you have a cohort of
peers that you can communicate with in
our community chat so
it's a very much more like a classroom
environment
just watching videos online and
it kind of these tend to cover complete
Suite of languages platforms tools
libraries
that are used in
data science data analytics
machine learning
so you can take a look at some of those
at the simply learned website and what
these do are they offer you a
certification programs here's a
particular example of a data science
Masters program which allows you to do
over 30 projects in Labs including a
Capstone project which you can show off
to employers as this is a data science
problem I chose to solve and here's how
I
created complete solution this is the
work that I do and you can evaluate it
and
if you're a student in India or you
asked many of our programs come with job
assistance
various levels
so just a quick question based on this
very brief thumbnail I've given you are
you uh who out there in the audience
would be interested in learning more
about these programs
and
how soon would you want to begin
learning if this is something that you
think is for you
I'm going to give you about 30 seconds
to answer that question
and in our
data science category we include data
science data analytics business
analytics we also have a category for
artificial intelligence and machine
learning so thanks for all
um
different programs that we offer
again all of them are delivered online
accessible from almost anywhere in the
world and
most of the devices you use can present
your course material
with the exception of programming of
course that you need to do on a laptop
or desktop because
the screen size
um so let me show you what the result is
here
told us
and
almost 90 percent of the people
responding said that they'd be
interested so
I'll share with you uh in the chat
a
link
you can contact
get to our website
for this link
here it is
this will take you to the category page
for our data science programs
from which you can look at individual
programs to see which one might interest
you most and also you can explore other
categories but navigating through the
website so
um thank you very much for being here
and thank thank you shubham for a
fascinating lesson uh look forward to
learning more about
classification techniques and other
areas in which
machine learning systems change our
lives so
I we'd had a webinar with the
CEO of zest money at one point in one of
the fascinating things about it is that
companies like that are able to do what
they do precisely because of this type
of of machine learning technique in
statistical technique that lets them
look at a lot of different factors
beyond the traditional income payment
history and that type of thing and allow
them to um
look at other aspects of consumer
behavior and find correlations between
that and credit worthiness so it's
because of these types of algorithms and
models that you're able
to start looking at those different
kinds of data that you might not have
associated with a credit risk decision
before so again thank you for that we
want to invite everyone in our audience
to connect with us on our social media
channels at simply learn on Facebook and
Twitter and simply learned on LinkedIn I
have put into the Q a and the
if you take a look through the Q a
answers you'll see shubham's um
Lincoln
I'll also uh take a quick look at that
I can repeat that verbally
just a moment
and
shubham is a LinkedIn he's Pandy Shivam
first last name first name 88.
yes you're right
so if you'd like to reach out to him
through that you can and we again look
forward to seeing you at Future simply
learn webinars and we hope we can
welcome you into the simply learn
learning community so again
have a wonderful evening or rest of the
day Wherever You Are
Texas tour thanks everybody